later today
thank you mr speaker
the degrading strip search of child q
two years ago
in a school that should have been a safe
place
at the hands of police officers who she
should have been able to trust has
caused anger and distress across the
country
on monday the policing minister failed
to answer four separate questions in
this chamber asking when he first knew
about child cue and what urgent action
he took in response so i asked the prime
minister
when did he first hear about the strip
search of child q in her school
and whether he believes that the
characteristic diver and delay of his
government in responding to this
appalling case is remotely acceptable
when it comes to the safety of children
[Music]
mr speaker i think that is a completely
ridiculous characterization of the
response
of the government because uh because of
course the the reports of this incident
are deeply distressing and deeply uh
concerning everybody uh everybody shares
her feelings about that mr speaker but
the metropolitan police have rightly
apologized and the iopc is investigating
and for that reason it would not be not
be right to comment further
sir oliver hill
thank you mr speaker people across north
east hertfordshire are coming together
to provide support and refuge to
families fleeing the invasion in ukraine
the bulldog and district action
committee are about to welcome four
families uh to our community and doesn't
he agree with me that this shows the
open-hearted generosity of the british
people and will he continue to do all
that he can with the refugees minister
to make this process as simple and
speedy as possible
i thank my uh honorable friend and i
also uh thank all those involved in the
two uh big schemes that we have now for
welcoming people uh from ukraine and the
homes for ukraine uh scheme is now open
i think about uh forty 000 uh have
already applied 150 000 uh homes across
this country people families across this
country have said they want to welcome
uh ukrainians that's a fantastic thing i
thank uh bulldog and district uh for
helping to lead the way welcome to the
leader of the opposition kirstjava
thank you mr speaker
800 loyal british workers fired over
zoom
instantly replaced by foreign agency
workers shipped in on less than the
minimum wage
if the prime minister can't stop that
what's the point of his government
well mr speaker we we condemn the
callous behavior of piano
and i think and i think that it is
i think that it is i think that it is no
way to treat hard-working
employees and i can tell him that we
will not sit by mr speaker because uh
because under section 194 of the trades
union and labor relations act of 1992 it
looks to me mr speaker as though the
company concerned has broken the law and
we will be taking action therefore and
we will we will be encouraging uh
workers themselves to take action under
the 1996 employment rights act both acts
mr speaker passed by conservative
governments
and
and
uh and if the company is found guilty uh
then they face fines running into
millions of pounds mr speaker and in
addition uh we will be taking steps to
protect all mariners who are working in
uk waters and ensure that they are all
paid the living wage mr speaker
mr speaker when owen patterson was on
the ropes the prime minister was
prepared to rip up the entire rulebook
to save his jobs
piano workers want him to show the same
fight in relation to them
the government had advanced warning of
these mass sackings
a memo was sent to the transport
secretary and to the prime minister's
office
but they didn't lift a finger to stop
them
did the prime minister not understand
the memo or did he just not bother to
read it
hi minister i think what uh what the
right honourable gentleman needs to rip
up mr speaker is it pre-scripted
questions
because i've just i've just answered
i've just answered the question and the
point the pointed issue the pointed
issue mr speaker is whether or not the
government was properly notified and it
doesn't and it's not about what happens
the previously i knew about it on the
thursday it became public but the the
company concerned has a duty to notify
the government 45 days uh mr speaker
before they take action of that kind
that is why we're taking the action that
we are to protect hard-working people
and what we're also doing by the way mr
speaker this month is lifting the living
wage for all workers across our country
uh by another thousand pounds so it's up
five thousand pounds since 2015.
[Music]
[Applause]
i think the prime minister just said he
knew about it on the day yeah i'd take
it from that aunt so the prime minister
didn't read his whatsapp briefing
let's test his rhetoric
mr speaker since the prime minister came
to office piano have received
over 38 million pounds of government
contracts
and the parent company dp world is lined
up for 50 million pounds of taxpayers
money under the free port scheme
the government is apparently reviewing
these contracts but reviews don't save
like save jobs
can the prime minister guarantee
guarantee that these companies will not
get a penny more of taxpayers money or a
single tax break until they reinstate
the workforce
mr speaker i think what uh house has
already heard is that we are taking
legal action against the against yes we
are against the company concerned under
under the 1992 uh employment uh and
trades union and labor relation uh act
and that is the the right thing to do
because it seems to me mr speaker that
they have broken the law but if he is
asking if he's asking this government to
do what labour usually want us to do and
actively pitchfork away investment
around the country from overseas mr
speaker then that is not what we will do
we'll take him to court we'll defend the
rights of british workers what we will
not do mr speaker is launch a
wholehearted campaign as they would want
against overseas investment because that
is that is completely wrong and wrong
for those workers mr speaker
well dp world must be quaking in their
boots
the primitive says how disappointed he
is in them whilst handing them 50
million pounds
prime minister said about the law
speaking of hollow reviews
as the law stands it's not illegal to
pay seafarers below the national minimum
wage even if
even if they're working out of uk ports
and in uk waters
two years ago prime minister
his government
admitted that that was unjustifiable two
years ago and promised two years ago
you've guessed it
to review it
two years on despite what he says today
nothing's been done leaving the gate
wide open for pno
british workers don't need another empty
review they need action so when will the
prime minister fix that gap in the law
mr speaker with great humility i i must
ask the right honourable gentleman to
listen to the answer that i gave
to the first question
because it would then help him uh to
scrap his third or fourth question and
try another one uh we are we are going
to address the uh the defects in the
1998
living wage act uh minimum wage act and
make sure that everybody everybody is
serving everybody serving in the uk
exclusive economic zone working in the
uk exclusive economic zone gets paid the
living wage as people do in the rest of
the country
yes
the problem is that's what he said two
years ago
it didn't happen a piano took advantage
of the gap left wide open by this prime
minister
piano's behavior comes off the back of a
string of fire and refi re-hire cases
profitable companies threatening to fire
workers unless they accept a pay cut
the prime minister keeps telling us just
how opposed he is to fire and rehire
but as we saw on monday
as we saw
mr speaker as we saw on monday he
doesn't have the backbone to ban it
whilst he sits on his hands more and
more workers are having their lives
thrown upside down by this appalling
practice what's good to them is a prime
minister who's all mouth and no trousers
[Applause]
the the most notable practitioners of
pharah and rihar are of course the
labour party uh themselves
uh but but i can uh he may be interested
he may be interested to know we will be
vindicating the rights of of british
workers uh uk employees under uh uk law
but the the law that the pno cut the
company themselves are allegedly relying
on uh was introduced i can tell him as a
result of eu directives and
never
never forget never forget mr speaker and
he may not like it that's the reality he
would have kept us he would have kept us
unable to change it unable to get out of
it uh he would have made it impossible
for us to protect uk employees in the
way that we're going to do but what
we're doing mr speaker above all is
ensuring uh the workers in this country
have the best protection of all which is
a job mr speaker and
under this government thanks to the
steps that we have taken thanks to the
stewardship of the economy by my right
honourable friend which you'll be
hearing about in a little bit more mr
speaker we have people in payroll
employment six hundred thousand more of
them than before the pandemic began
[Applause]
[Music]
he can complain what he likes but on
monday he ordered all of his lot to
abstain on a vote to ban fire and rehire
exactly
and they all they all did
and then mr speaker
to add insult to injury after the vote
his party posted a message saying that
where possible they will look to find
piano workers new jobs
pathetic
they don't want new jobs
they want their old jobs back
they don't want a prime minister
hoisting the white flag they want him to
fight for their livelihoods
82 000 seafarers in this country i've
spoken to dockers engineers debt cans
and sailors they're all worried about
what this means for them
this morning one of them said to me if
piano can get away with this other
companies will get rid of us to
replace this with cheap labor from
abroad why does the prime minister think
that they will take a crumb of comfort
from his half-assed bluster and waffle
today
mr speaker piano plainly aren't going to
get away with it any more than any more
than anyone
any more than any other company that
treats his employees in that scandalous
way uh mr speaker and uh
this is a this is a historic moment for
this country actually uh because it's
now two years since uh two years to the
day uh that we went into lockdown and uh
that plunged this country into the
biggest uh deepest loss of output that
we've seen uh in our lifetimes and uh
thanks to the chancellor who protected
the economy who protected jobs who
protected companies
we've now been able to come out faster
and more effectively than any other
comparable economy we have unemployment
back down to 3.9 percent we have 600 000
more people on the payroll mr speaker
and the best assurance we can give
workers around the country is that the
economy is now bigger than it was before
the pandemic began and we will continue
to get the big calls right
as we got the big calls right during the
pandemic they got the big calls wrong
they would do absolutely nothing to
protect workers level and piano workers
and mr speaker because because not only
would they have kept us in lockdown and
kept those ships in port mr speaker
unable to move that's the reality it has
kept those ships in port but mr speaker
there has never been a labor government
that left
left office with unemployment lower than
when they began
[Music]
thank you mr speaker i strongly support
the government's intention to make
england smoke free by 2030 but on the
current trajectory we're going to miss
that target
it is vital that we encourage or
discourage young people from starting to
smoke and encourage people that smoke
already to give up
so does my right honourable friend agree
with me that it's now time to raise the
age of legal sale of tobacco products
from 18 to 21
and impose
a levy on the profits of the big tobacco
companies to raise 700 million pounds
that we can put to smoking cessation
services on the basis that the polluter
must pay
well thank you i thank you very much uh
and uh he's absolutely right about
smoking it's the biggest single cause of
preventable death in this in this
country uh as he'll know javid khan obe
is undertaking an independent review of
smokey and i'm sure he will want to uh
take uh my honorable friends uh
suggestions into a cat
speed spokesperson leader of the snp in
blackfoot
thank you mr speaker in a matter of
seconds at 12 16 a aircraft is due to
depart heathrow airport a virgin
atlantic aircraft to go to warsaw to
pick up 50 young orphans that have left
ukraine
that are coming to spend the next period
of their life in scotland with the
sanctuary that we can offer them and i
would like to
take this opportunity to thank everyone
that has helped to make sure that we can
offer a new start to these young people
away from the war and in particular
the the governments in in london and in
edinburgh and in particular to thank the
immigration
minister the member for torbay and the
refugee minister in the house of lords
lord harrington this is a good day for
these 50 young people but let's hope
that it's the beginning of something
much more significant for many more
young people that we can offer sanctuary
too
mr speaker this morning
we have official confirmation that
inflation is at its highest level in 30
years
but families don't need official
confirmation to know that the cost of
food and energy are now at a price they
simply can't afford
the very people who've borne the brunt
of the health pandemic are now being
hammered
by the poverty pandemic this is not just
the cost of living crisis this is an
emergency that is why in scotland the
snp government
is doubling the scottish child payment
and raising benefits it controls by six
percent double the rate the chancellor
has proposed for the benefits he has
control over
so this is a very simple question for
the prime minister if he truly
understands that this is an emergency
will he match the scottish government's
commitment
and lift all benefits by six percent
prime minister
uh i thank him very much and the the uh
we will recognize the uh inflation
global inflation uh is causing uh a real
cost of living crisis not just here but
around uh the world in in the us
inflation is now running it uh more than
eight percent uh where we're at uh the
levels in other european countries we're
doing everything we can to help people
uh the chancellor's put another 9.1
billion pounds into uh reducing the cost
of energy uh for families uh but but
i i don't know quite what he's shouting
out mr speaker but uh what we want to do
more and scotland i can tell him is uh
in the lead in helping this country to
solve its energy uh problems uh not just
with more offshore wind uh mr speaker
but by uh abandoning the the phobia of
our own hydrocarbons which i think are
going to be vital uh for transition and
avoid us being blackmailed uh by putin's
russia and
on uh on his point about the uh the
orphans mr speaker i'm i'm grateful to
him for uh for his efforts i thank him
and it's another example if i may say uh
without uh embarrassing him further of
the burgeoning cooperation
between us
well of course mr speaker we want to
make sure we open our doors in scotland
and and welcome refugees that we have
that generosity of of spirit but we'll
leave that there for now
can i can i say to the prime minister
the inflation is at six percent and
increasing we need to make sure that
those the most vulnerable have that
increase in benefits that they need
in order to pay for fuel and they
chancellor needs to ditch the official
photographer and listen to martin lewis
family finances are at breaking point
they can't tighten their budgets anymore
these families have no room for maneuver
but the truth is
that the chancellor does
lower borrowing and increased taxes
means it is sitting with 28 billion
pounds to spend today
but instead
this chancellor is making a political
choice the choice to push people further
into hardship by hiking taxis cutting
universal credit
and giving companies free rein to slash
workers pay through fire and rehire
so the test for the prime minister is
this
will the government use the full 20
billion pounds they are sitting on to
scrap the national insurance tax site
and put money into people's pockets or
we simply make this tory poverty
pandemic even worse
prime minister right well i i just
advise mystic meg uh over here that uh
we have only yeah he has only 10 minutes
uh to wait before he'll have the answer
to that question mr speaker
good study
thank you mr speaker um i warmly welcome
the improvements to our national ukraine
refugee response
but in the weeks since these improved
measures numbers fleeing putin's
invasion have sadly doubled to 3.5
million and are expected to go even
higher so does the prime minister agree
our response must still move much much
faster with a shift to processing
applications in the uk cutting the red
tape and bureaucracy so we can match the
scale of europe's worst humanitarian
crisis since the second world war
prime minister
uh mr speaker i think he's i think he's
right that uh we are going to uh see
many more people coming in he's right
that the instincts of this country are
to be as generous as possible and that's
why
we've made sure that applications can
now be uh processed online uh very
quickly uh mr speaker so people can come
here uh with their passports and uh
under the family reunion scheme alone i
think the numbers are now running in
excess of 16 000 uh people coming here
kenny mccaskill thank you mr speaker
whilst off gem can cap rising gas and
electricity bills other fuels such as
heating oil lpg and solid fuel remain
unregulated
many households in rural scotland depend
on such fuels there are also areas awash
with energy both on and offshore yet
with huge and rising numbers in fuel
poverty will the prime minister regulate
and cap such fuels to alleviate hardship
and end the perversity of energy-rich
scotland but fuel poor scots
well i i i thank him very much and uh i
think he's right that energy rich uh
scotland and the the hydrocarbons that
uh we have in this country should be
used to help the british people and that
uh we shouldn't be
needlessly reliant on oil and gas from
from putin's russia and uh i think
that's the policy of uh of alba uh and
uh unfortunately it's not yet the policy
of the of the smp jason mccartney thank
you mr speaker i'm so proud to represent
a vibrant ukrainian community in
huddersfield and valley and this friday
at the ukrainian club in huddersfield
they'll be collecting medical supply
donations to send to ukraine and the
surrounding nations will the prime
minister join me in thanking all of our
community in west yorkshire have rallied
around their ukrainian neighbors and
friends and also continue to put the uk
at the forefront of donations of not
only humanitarian and medical supplies
but also the military aid that is
allowing the ukrainian people to fight
so bravely against putin and his cronies
[Music]
thank you very much i thank the
ukrainian community in yorkshire for
everything they're doing of course the
ukrainian communities up and down the
country and the the people of this
country as a whole i am proud that we
are the uh the biggest uh bilateral
donor i think other than the united
states uh in aid to to ukraine and yes
i'm also proud as i know the whole house
is of the work that is being done
continuously to give the ukrainians the
the tools they need to defend themselves
rave stringer
mr speaker the football association are
refusing to move the semi-final between
liverpool and manchester city uh from
wembley there are no trains from the
northwest that day which means 50 or 60
000 people will have to go by road but
for the funds but for the environment
unfortunately
uh this is typical of the insensitivity
of the fa yeah who think that
uh fit and proper people to run our
football clubs are russian kleptocrats
and people who are wanted for human
rights abuses does the prime minister
agree with me that now is the time to
legislate to set up an independent
regulator uh for football with fan
involvement
prime minister
uh well i thank you very much i i'm not
going to uh comment on the travel
arrangements for the particular uh match
though uh though
the deputy leader of the labour party uh
uh shouts for me to secure her a train
i'll do and i'm sure that everybody has
heard that the fa would have heard the
message uh that he's that he's given uh
but what i what i can say mr speaker is
i do agree uh with uh my uh my honorable
friend who's just conducted a review uh
on the matter uh uh that we should
indeed have an independent a regulator
for football
olympic craft yeah yeah
thank you mr speaker my right-hand
friend the prime minister is a great
champion for steel and we've just had
brilliant news on the removal of the u.s
steel tariffs will he reaffirm the
commitment he made at the dispatch box
on the 31st of january that the
chancellor will bring forward a package
of measures on our steel energy costs
and if the chancellor isn't able to make
good on that commitment today will he
ensure he does so as soon as he can yeah
[Applause]
i
agree with her uh passionately and i
think that it is vital that uh we undo
the damage done by the insane uh
policies of the the labor government the
previous labor government that whacked
up the cost of of energy for british
industry including steel
i will be bringing forward a british
energy security strategy uh mr speaker
that will address uh the needs of
british steel british ceramics and the
whole of british industry
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker i'm sure the prime
minister will share my delight but
bradford has been shortlisted to be the
uk city of culture 2025 and will want to
offer his support for our bid it would
bring immense benefits than kudos to
britain's youngest city we have over 120
languages spoken across bradford its
unique cultural heritage diversity and
let's not forget the amazing food the
birthplace of david hockney and the
brontes bradford has it all apartments
from mr speaker government support one
practical way in which he could help is
reverse the transport sector is snug to
bradford in the integrated rail plan so
i asked the prime minister will he look
again at this and commit to delivering a
real northern powerhouse rail including
a stop in bradford city
mr speaker i congratulate bradford on
being uh shortlisted in the way that uh
uh that wonderful city has been but i
think she's wrong about what the
integrated role plan said because
already uh already it's committing uh to
cut the journey times from memory uh
from leeds to bradford from 20 minutes
to 12 minutes if i if i remember
correctly and and mr speaker uh we are
continuing to look at ways of making
sure that high-speed rail goes direct to
bradford
thank you uh mr speaker the horrifying
effects events in ukraine must be
central to our focus and we should all
possible to stand together in support
a ward in europe also has challenging
domestic outcomes with higher energy
costs rising food prices and effects on
supplies and inflation and across the
economy in general
does the prime minister agree with me
that this is a time where we need to
come together as a nation and anyone
seeking to weaponize putin's deliberate
and calculated consequences of the war
will only undermine the unity of our
nation at a time when europe is in
crisis yeah prime minister i i thank you
my right honourable friend very much for
what he has said and i think that one of
the most important things that has uh
confounded vladimir putin has not only
been the uh the resistance of the
ukrainians the heroic resistance of the
ukrainians but the unity of the uh of
the rest of the world and the the i must
say so far the relative unity the
important unity of this house
rebecca longbelly thank you mr speaker
the prime minister has been very
supportive of nuclear testing veterans
so i'm sure he will be shocked that
today the mirror has uncovered 140 pages
of data previously hidden in a footnote
of a 1988 government report
there's now concern that the high court
and this house may have been
inadvertently misinformed in 2008 when
told that only 159 men in uk nuclear
weapons tests were exposed to dangerous
radiation when today's data shows
exposure numbers were actually 2
314.
will he urgently investigate this and
arrange to meet personally in downing
street with my constituent her granddad
and other nuclear testing veterans to
bring an end to this national scandal
prime minister well i thank the
honourable member very much for bringing
uh those facts uh new facts to the
intention of the house and i know that
my uh my office has already been in
touch with the group concerned to make
sure that we have a proper meeting uh
and i hope very much that uh that she
will be there and uh we'll be able to
discuss uh all the issues that she's
raised percy thank you mr speaker can i
begin by thanking the government and the
home secretary in particular as chair of
the appg on surrogacy for her work to
bring a to bring ukrainian surrogates to
safety here sadly in my role as chair of
the appg on anti-semitism the news isn't
so positive we heard from jewish
students recently who are suffering
record
anti-semitic attacks on university
campuses including allegations of them
being marked down by their own
professors this is completely outrageous
and you would expect the nus to be on
their side but instead of helping those
students the nus has been
inviting somebody who's engaged in
anti-semitic conspiracy theory as a
rapper to a conference can the promise
do everything in his power to ensure
campuses are a safe place for british
jewish students
prime minister uh well mr speaker i
think that uh our universities for far
too long have uh been uh tolerant of
casual or indeed systematic uh
anti-semitism and uh that's why uh it is
very important that we now have uh i
hope that uh uh everybody understands
the need for change and for rapid and
irreversible change uh but it's also
important that we have an anti-semitism
task force uh devoted uh to rooting out
anti-semitism uh in education at all
levels mary kelly boy thank you mr
speaker
last week the government did nothing to
stop p or ferry's second 800 seafarers
on the spot on the same day the work and
pensions minister was forced to come to
the house to announce over 1100 dwp job
losses and 42 center closures risking a
further 7 000 jobs including 1300 in the
north east
working people are once again being
hammered by this government in the
middle of a cost of living crisis
causing genuine suffering why won't the
prime minister act to protect local
communities from losing real high
quality jobs
prime minister well mr speaker i renew
my sympathies with the the case of the
with the pno uh workers and i've
explained to the house what where what
we're doing uh and we will uh but what
we're also doing mr speaker is helping
uh the workforce up and down the country
to get the the coaching they need we've
doubled the number of work coaches mr
speaker and uh what we're seeing is uh
employment uh climbing we're seeing uh
vacancies growing uh mr speaker we are
helping this country into work and
that's what conservatives do
steve brian
go about their lives or even get to work
because their driving licenses are stuck
at the dvla
would the prime minister make it clear
at the dispatch box that the service
from the agency falls significantly
below what we expected
and would he ask the transport secretary
to meet with me and any other member of
this house i think we may need a big
room
to explain how we can help them out of
the hole they've put themselves in
absolutely prime minister uh
yeah yes mr speaker i think like
everybody in this house i've read some
surprising things about what's been
going on at the dvla i do think that we
need to make sure that they give uh
they're given every possible
encouragement and support uh to expedite
uh the the supply of driving licenses uh
to the people of this country weston
thank you mr speaker it's nice to see
the prime minister back i missed him
last week
a fantasy castle
perhaps snow white two
certainly girls girls girls were
promised at a party less burlesque more
berlusconi
according to
a former minister it seems the prime
minister has been entertained at these
bunga bunga parties hosted by his close
friend
a russian oligarch
given his many weaknesses could leave
him open to blackmail
why does the prime minister think
that mi6
why does the prime
right
why does the prime minister think that
mi6
may not entirely trust him
well
mr speaker i'm afraid i i i missed i i
last week i wasn't here to benefit from
one of these elaborately conflicted uh
questions uh i i i
admire his style uh mr speaker i i'm
afraid i've simply failed to detect any
any crude oil of substance in the
minister
the the minestrone of nonsense uh that
he just spoken
[Applause]
oh yeah thank you mr speaker
mr speaker wrexham is a town based on
brewing mining and football a town
involved
in aspiration prosperity and creativity
whilst retaining its welsh identity can
the prime minister congratulate rexum on
being shortlisted for the city of
culture
this is the first welsh town to do so
prime minister uh well mr speaker
wrexhams are not only uh the city of
shortness of the city of culture and all
that with all the distinctions that she
mentions but it is also the city of
vaccines um mr speaker uh because
without though without the astrazeneca
vaccines bottled in wrecks and we
wouldn't be uh well it literally
wouldn't be where we are today
[Applause]
mr speaker former treasury minister lord
agnew has described the chancellor's
failure on covid fraud as one of the
most colossal cock-ups in recent
government management and taxpayers are
paying for it
we now know the chancellor's failure has
cost the country 11.8 billion pounds
almost exactly the same as the amount
national insurance is going to be
increased on working people in the
coming year
does the prime minister think it is fair
to demand working people pay the bill
for the chancellor's failures
uh mr speaker i remember him when he was
doing planning at islington council and
uh and
a complete clock i've been made of that
uh but uh what what what i could what i
can tell him is that this is a this
government uh has made sure that we got
the ppe we got the supplies that were
needed in record time and that was
absolutely vital and at a time mr
speaker when they were calling on us uh
to go to go further and faster and never
forget under under the last labor
government there was 23 billion pounds
uh lost in fraud every year angela
richardson thank you mr speaker um i
welcome the important interim report
from dr hillary cass in which she
highlights the need for more research
into our young girls why so many of them
are presenting with gender distress well
my right honourable friend agreed to
meet with me and other concerned
colleagues and to discuss how we can
constructively support these young
people who are experiencing gender
distress prime minister uh yes mr
speaker i would be very happy to uh meet
with my uh with my honorable friend and
i think that this is one of those uh
issues that uh the whole house is coming
to realize is one that requires extreme
uh sensitivity tact love
and care we must recognize that when
people
make a want to make a transition in
their lives that they should be treated
with the maximum possible generosity and
and respect we have systems in this
country uh that uh allow that for and
have done for a long time we should be
very proud of it but i i just do i do
want to say in addition mr speaker i
think when it comes to uh distinguishing
between
a man and a woman uh that the basic
facts of
biology remain overwhelmingly important
mr speaker
[Applause]
the prime minister met the chairman of p
o owners dp world
to discuss setting up a free port in
london
and just last year the foreign secretary
met dp world as well
dp world run ports in the uk
which employ more than 600 workers
so if the prime minister wants to remove
the latest suspicion of his conflicts of
interest
will he tell his due by millionaire
friends
that if they want contracts to run free
ports here
they must reinstate p o workers and
guarantee the jobs of dp world workers
too
we need to use more moderate and
temperate language
prime minister
mr speaker i have over one uh one
overwhelming interest and that is to
protect and preserve the jobs and
livelihood of the british people and
that's what we're doing and that's what
we'll do with the piano workers but
we'll also make sure that we continue to
attract overseas investment in the
record overseas investment in the record
ways that we currently are they would
they would drive it away we won't mr
speaker
this year marks the 50th anniversary of
the expulsion of asians from uganda the
country where i was born
under ted heath's government
people across the country opened up
their homes for many of these asians
who then settled and become became part
of the fabric of our great nation
that british generosity
is again being seen
as people open up their homes for people
fleeing ukraine as they come to our
country
may i urge the prime minister
to pick up those files from 50 years ago
wipe off the dust
and take on board those positive lessons
so we can ensure that the homes for
ukraine scheme has the maximum success
yes mr speaker and i think the whole
country can be proud of the uh the way
the uk uh uh welcomed people fleeing
idiyar means uh uganda and i i'm sure
that there are many members of the of
the house or several members of the
house and i know the home secretary
herself uh her family was a beneficiary
of of that scheme and that moment this
country is overwhelmingly generous to
people fleeing uh in fear of their lives
uh we will continue to be so ultimate
800 british workers
sacked
to be replaced with foreign exploited
agency workers on less than two quid an
hour
the prime minister
can pass an instrument now
to close the loophole
so that the national minimum wage
applies on uk
international
routes
is he going to stand up for british
workers
or
the oil states
dictator dubai
all right mr speaker i'm i'm grateful
for uh his question and i uh i knew he
was going to ask it uh and he was right
to ask it i anticipated this question
earlier on we're going to make sure that
everybody working in the everybody
working in the uk
exclusive economic zone gets paid the
living wage and mr speaker we'll do it
as fast as we possibly can with their
assistance
the elfic yes
i welcome the prime minister's
commitment to take legal action to hold
piano ferries and dp world to account
and i call again on them to reverse
their action and reinstate the workers
already badly affected by this business
including on the roads and business
community will my right not have a
friend meet with me to discuss specific
support for our affected area including
the age upgrade for the national
transport blinks and the east kent
enterprise zone to cover and include the
port of dover
[Applause]
mr speaker
she's writing what she says about the
about piano and about the 800 workers
and uh i i will make sure that she gets
all the meetings she needs uh about uh
to make sure that uh dover we continue
with all our fantastic investments uh in
dover whether uh transport or uh
education or otherwise
we're just going to give it a minute for
people to leave before we start the
statement anyone who wants to leave
please leave now let's clear the benches
well there we have the end of prime
minister's questions and a minutes break
before we move on to the spring
statement with chancellor sunaka let's
just quickly bring in beth rugby here
piano um as we anticipated was quite a
um the i suppose main subject really of
the day it was it was and and uh you saw
natalie outfit there whose constituents
have been badly affected and she came
under quite a lot of heavy criticism on
the ground
from her constituents the pm there with
some breaking news actually uh where he
announced in the commons obviously
anticipating that this is what kia
starman would ask him about he said well
the government is not going to sit by
over
a
sacking of workers
without notice and he said it appears
the company has broken the law and the
government will take action so let's see
how that develops
there is a wider political